et là
et c'est aussi
et puis mon dieu condensé du peuple
je ne veux pas travailler laisse moi finir
manger comment faire attention travail 65
grammes et
dis moi une table de noel si tu continue
donc tu es brutal
quantités prix de ceux très gros
les problèmes c'est tout
et là
le positif là à ce moment nous
effectue l'achat en échange ou en garantie et
contrôle, mais à partir de là, nous
allons au même
et là
C'est là
et il y a aussi la collection coronavirus
qui à mon avis est super
mis à l'échelle le pouvoir destructeur de ce
de ce virus et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et là
dans quelques autorités étatiques
et les municipalités devraient abandonner le concept
de la terre brûlée à l'interdiction de
transport la fermeture des commerces et la
confinement de masse donc président
comme tu dis respectueusement
ce n'est pas une grippe ce n'est pas un rhume
zinho est une affaire sérieuse que le président a
l'interprétation en tant que capitaine du
armée qui n'a aucune connaissance
pas d'expérience scientifique et de santé
même la santé publique ne fonctionne pas sur des conjectures
dans votre position dans votre testament
personnel ne crains pas si grave que ça gâche
la vie des gens a pris près de 40
millions de travailleurs indépendants
Le Brésil ne peut pas s'arrêter aux vendeurs de rue
forains ingénieurs architectes
avocats maçons
et là
[Musique]
C'est là
et là
[Musique]